こんにちははじめ必要です
a 今
展示今ベンチで雑感はず舌がおかしいと
思うといいと思うんですけどもこれが p
え
はい風っこにがってなんでこんなことが
あったかっていうと最近あの写真東武機会
があってちょっとダイエットして闊歩よく
するをかなぁ思ってダイエットしてるん
ですね食事制限めちゃくちゃして言ったら
ビタミン不足話とわからないんですけど今
靴の中に4雷電横ありますツアーもうした
米だけした会いたくてレッグ上は舌を
動かしたくないという状況で今動画を撮っ
てますね食べ物食べると口が痛いんですよ
麺類だったら霧セーフみたいなとこあるん
で今回は素敵な麺類準備しましたこちら
山わさび塩焼きそばバナー見た感じは普通
の山わさびの集約とかですねみてください
これあここ刺激が強い商品でよく見て
くださいこのパッケージの逆になり20%
の部分が赤くなっています
こっちはいいですねーもうとても危険と
いうことをこれ詰めしてるんですねこう
いっちぱねぇ
に対してねこれ何がすごいかといいますと
なんか絶対にむせる焼きそばという名前で
なんか2噂になってるらしいので音階
pv 再生でば sub-q 大丈夫な
痛かった
やりたくても空は意義だって踊って1
食べるんですけど個人としては違うぜひ
とも村絶対目線っていう誰も食べてみたい
んで早速作っていこうと思います宜しく
チャペ食べ
今のわざとでしょうー
th
ああああああ
パッラム落ちウォッチいいん
でーん
dell 者数
ん
tよし
uh
いやあああええ山わさびがなんだかわかん
ないけど絶対にバーセビンの匂いだこれ
[音楽]
ん
メーカー
平和たて怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い俺も混ぜて
いるだけどにめっちゃ目行ったけどいます
というまあそんなことあるポイント2なぜ
ばぜてくれる3度目が痛くなるのがある見
た感情人前多いしそうな何か強い焼きそ
ばっぽいんですけどもピアスも絶対に
見せる焼きそばがあんな普通はパッケージ
てうってわけがない true で早速
ちょっと食べてみたいと思います6せる
わけないでしょみんな美味しそうの駅そば
ごときで医療者いただきます
[音楽]
ふんっ
はぁんっ
はぁっ
can
うっ
バッハ
わっほっ
何時かまってまってなんか一気に食ったら
やばいなってしまってこれでて空を見上げ
ます
いってん
ん
さあ
薄い薄い今薄いとこ引きましたソースの
薄いところだったらなんでも食べるんです
けどバチバチかかっているところはもう
デー
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
うんっこれやばいな
は去りですはうわさ火の塊をかぶって食っ
てえーっやってる感じがすごいです
ちょっと少しずつなら食べれそうな感じも
していただきます
[音楽]
うん甘いパスし大丈夫大丈夫ですいただき
ます
[音楽]
パパ痛いでですへ nbd 線沿いだじゃ
んだあああ
マジでこれ部分的に本当にむせるな
美味しいんでて本当に美味しいけどすげー
みせちゃう
おっ
[音楽]
あ
花2
大変山わさびがすごい言う横へ
[音楽]
ああ
うんあああっあっー食べました汗
サーロインですね結構汗だっても結構辛い
ですねなんでその力からとかのからじゃ
なくてほんとわさびのあのツーン今まで
食べてきたわさび賞金一番当たりつんでし
たこれいやーこれ6せずに食べれるといる
のかなってくれほんと強かったので是非と
も操船してみてください僕はオーバー
リアクションとか演技でやってんでしょと
かいう人もいると思うんで近くにいた後輩
で仕掛けてみましたどうぞ
頂下さい
あっはぁボドゲ家です入ってをぞすると
風船ちゃんと
入って実は行ってに
以来ますはい
par パパ
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ん
第酒場何が届ですねっ
いっ
pou
dou
[音楽]
douhp